there's the shot nicely done ted
skating oh my goodness well we did it at
cosmo at the ice rink not too long ago
which was a fabulous experience it
always kicks off our holiday and then
we're of course gonna hit
the downtown summerlin one i think after
christmas this is a fun one
because you also have the the actual
train is over here uh-huh but i was here
this weekend i'm telling you guys
everybody
that the hot chocolate station right
here has red velvet hot chocolate
and it's the best ever okay harlow my
kid
went through half of it she goes daddy i
don't think i'm gonna finish i'm like
give me both of them
i was like double fisting both hot
chocolates it's worth it all right
yeah that's the uh the rock rink down at
the downtown summerlin great shot here
from a red rock station tower cam
they got the big tree there too they got
the open field so you can toss around
the football or the frisbee whatever you
need
temperatures have been great lately and
looks like that has been the case today
67 degrees are high
and that put us one degree shy of the
actual record for this date
which is 68 degrees back in 1950 42
overnight for the low
here are valley temperatures right now
new neighborhoods here to show you
centennial hills at 56 up there in
providence
same goes for sky canyon 56 for sumlin
52 aliante north las vegas and downtown
both at 59
sunrise manor at 63 green valley and
whitney ranch at 59
henderson at 55 and rhodes ranch and
mountains edge southern highlands both
at 54. and same goes for seven hills at
this six o'clock
hour 54 for prep 54 for boulder city as
well in laflin coming in at 61 degrees
there's our doppler network again
very dry conditions across the desert
southwest all the way to southern
california however that will change
this time next week as we'll track a
system that will come in
through southern california coast and
move its way towards our region
bringing us chances for showers first
though let's focus
on this first one that's going to impact
this on wednesday in the form of
wind we will have breezy winds on
wednesday no rain though
some leftover breezes we think from the
north on thursday too but
will be the big wind day on wednesday
and some breezes also will continue on
sunday
and monday from that system that will
bring us those chances for showers now
we had that we broke that streak last
week remember that we were all over that
for you and warned you about it
there's those chances again on monday
slight chance on sunday mainly mountains
but monday
the better chance only about 20 chance
right now better chances in the
mountains for mountain snow
each day the forecast changes so we'll
keep our eye on this
and be sure to watch eight news now our
8 news weather team to make sure
we'll see the impacts of that and when
that really is going to happen or if it
happened at all 43 degrees overnight
66 tomorrow in the afternoon that will
be another mild day 10 degrees above
normal here's your seven-day forecast
breezy winds on wednesday like we talked
about
there's christmas eve and christmas day
not bad at all we'll have clouds on
thursday but remain dry
warming up on christmas day looking good
on the weekend and then there's those
chances for showers
a week from today that is your most
accurate forecast don't forget to catch
us at 11.
kirsten thank you all right thanks ted